-The Republican Party
and conservative movement
are now so committed
to an alternate reality
where Donald Trump
won the 2020 election
that if you're a Republican
and you depart even slightly
from that deranged lie,
you'll be punished.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Republicans as a party
are just fully out of ideas.
They have nothing constructive
to add
to the national discourse.
They spend their time
whining hysterically
about hamburgers and Dr. Seuss
and are still trying to get
the last election overturned.
They're so desperate to be
outraged about utter nonsense,
they spent an entire day
getting mad
about the Snow White ride
at Disneyland.
-Cancel culture is coming
for a Disney classic.
-Cancel culture extending
its reach -- deep breath --
this time to Snow White.
The mob going after
Prince Charming
for kissing the Princess,
or Snow White, without consent.
Snow White could now be
snow woke.
[ Clicks tongue ]
-Yep. Cancel culture going after
poor little Snow White.
-When I woke up and I saw
Snow White is now in trouble,
Molly, I was like,
"Well, it must be Monday."
-Critics are demanding
Disneyland remove
the "true love kiss" scene
from the new ride Snow White.
-So now they're trying
to cancel Snow White.
Your thoughts?
-This ride at Disneyland.
-Yeah. Disneyland.
-You know, sometimes I think,
"We are so screwed."
I don't know where
these jack-a-loons
come up with this stuff.
-Probably the same place you
came up with "jack-a-loons."
What the hell is that, some kind
of cryptocurrency for pirates?
"Prepare to be boarded,
and upload all your jack-a-loons
to my account.
Arr!
What's your Wi-Fi?
I think we need to
get on the same Wi-Fi
for the upload to take place."
You're a United States senator.
You should be spending your time
talking about stuff that
actually matters
instead of a ride at Disneyland,
unless you want to talk about
Mr. Toad's Wild Ride,
because it is very insane to me
that, in that ride,
which is for small children,
Mr. Toad goes to hell.
And doesn't come out,
it should be noted.
It just ends there,
in hell, then the ride's over.
"Well, I hope you enjoyed it,
kids,
and remember, follow
traffic laws or else."
As for Prince Charming,
I just think the dude
needs to pick a princess,
which would have made
a pretty good 2007 movie
starring Owen Wilson
as Prince Charming
and Vince Vaughn
as his best friend.
"Buddy, buddy, buddy, I know
they're all beautiful honeys,
but you have to make a choice
and leave some for
the rest of us.
You know, because I asked
Snow White for her number,
and she says
she's dating Charming.
And Sleeping Beauty
gives me the cold shoulder
because she's dating Charming.
And, like, all that's left
is ogres and trolls,
and that's not a comment
on anyone's looks.
They're literally
ogres and trolls."
I have a cold that I thought
would improve my Vince Vaughn,
but I see now that it hurt it.
Well, we can't unwind the clock.
At this point,
it's only a matter of time
before Fox News spends a week
running segments
warning that Biden is sending
his army
of Antifa super soldiers
to your house
to take away your Beanie Babies.
So they're obsessed
with election lies
and insane culture war
bull[bleep]
Meanwhile, Joe Biden seems to
have checkmated Republicans
with a strategy so shocking,
it never occurred to them --
doing popular things
that people like.
-Thanks to the Biden
administration's accelerated
vaccination push,
new cases of COVID
are at the lowest point
since the beginning of October.
In addition,
Biden's stimulus package
has provided the spark
he promised.
Look at some of these numbers.
U.S. gross domestic product,
GDP, hit 6.4%.
That's the second-best
quarterly reading since 2003.
Thanks to the stimulus,
Americans actually have
more money to spend.
The amount of money
an individual household has
after taxes
increased $2.36 trillion,
67% in the first quarter
of 2021.
-And as President Biden
completes his first 100 days
in office,
a majority of Americans are more
optimistic about the next year.
That is according to
a new ABC News/Ipsos poll.
Nearly two-thirds, 64%,
are optimistic about
the direction of the country.
-Wow, optimism. That is not
a feeling Americans are used to.
A year ago, we were all
going to the grocery store
in homemade HAZMAT suits
and rubber gloves,
fighting over toilet paper
and oat milk.
And, yeah, okay, I'm sorry
I live in a part of the country
where people were fighting
over oat milk.
Sue me.
It's the only thing my wife will
let me put in my Kashi cereal.
And if I come back with anything
other than the actual
OATLY! brand,
I have to sit quietly
in the corner
and drink my dandelion tea
with agave and turmeric
because she says turmeric
is good for my memory
and I'm sweet like agave.
So after four years
of constant misery,
there's finally reason
for optimism,
especially when you see
the President
set an ambitious goal
of getting shots
to at least 70% of adults
by July 4th,
which is believable
because he's already hit
several of the goals
he's already set for himself,
like 200 million shots
in his first 100 days.
It's such a jarring change
from the Trump era,
when he would set
outlandish goals
without absolutely any
credibility to back them up,
and that's because
he could never stop talking,
even when he was
saying something scripted.
"Today I'm announcing
that by July 4th,
70% of American adults
will be vaccinated.
And we're going to be doing it
on Mars.
That's right, folks.
Just hop in your car,
head on down to Cape Canaveral.
My team's
shaking their head no,
but I'm pretty confident
this is how it's gonna go.
And when you get there, you'll
be given the shot of your choice
and a free MyPillow,
courtesy of my friend
and a great patriot
who will also be piloting
the ship to Mars Mike Lindell."
"I found proof of voter fraud
on Mars.
The aliens hacked
our voting machines
so Joe Biden
could outlaw Beanie Babies
and take away Da Bears."
[ Laughter ]
The cold helps the Lindell.
So we have one party that,
for all its faults,
is interested in
governing and solving problems
and another that's obsessed with
lies and conspiracy theories
and feigned
culture-war grievances,
and they're still being led,
in large part,
by the disgraced,
twice-impeached former President
who never won the popular vote,
never once cracked 50% approval.
-Ted Cruz sharing this picture.
It shows him sitting
next to Donald Trump
at Mar-a-Lago tonight.
The senator's saying
that he had a great dinner,
adding that Trump
is in great spirits.
Cruz says the evening
was spent talking
about working together
to retake the White House
and to try to take back Congress
and the Senate in 2022.
-All right, first of all,
you only say
someone's in great spirits
when there's reason to believe
they shouldn't be
in great spirits,
like if they're in the hospital
or they're with Ted Cruz.
Also, why does Mar-a-Lago
look like
the inside
of a mobster's fish tank?
Did you guys eat next to the
castle or the treasure chest?
"Do you want to pay with cash,
check, or jack-a-loons?"
And, Ted, do you ever
spend any time in Texas,
or do you just hop from
one luxury resort to the other
with a brief layover in Congress
to take a nap?
Senator, should I book a hotel
for your layover in D.C.?
"No need.
I'll just sleep on the job."
And lastly, I know whenever
Ted Cruz grovels before Trump,
we point out that
Trump insulted his wife
and accused his dad
of killing JFK,
but I also
just wanted to point out
that Trump insulted his wife
and accused his dad
of killing JFK.
Trump must be thinking, "What do
I have to do to get this guy
to stop wanting
to have dinner with me?"
Anyway, the point is,
Republicans have to
keep making this dumb pilgrimage
to Mar-a-Lago
because they and their voters
are fully committed
to what Trump represents.
His brand of corrupt
authoritarianism
and racist culture-war paranoia
is still popular within the GOP,
even if it's deeply unpopular
with everyone else,
as evidenced by Trump's
terrible polling numbers
and Biden's
high polling numbers.
The GOP is now so committed
to the deranged lie that Trump
actually won the election
that if you simply state
the obvious, that he lost,
that there was
no widespread fraud,
and that he tried to foment
a violent insurrection
on January 6th
to retain his grip on power,
the GOP will punish you,
as Utah Senator Mitt Romney and
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
have recently discovered.
-Senator Mitt Romney booed
by fellow Republicans
at a party convention
on Saturday in Utah.
Listen to this.
-I don't hide the fact
that I wasn't a fan
of our last President's
character issues.
And I'm also no fan --
[ Crowd booing ]
-Axios reporting
House Republicans
moving closer to ousting
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
from leadership
and are already
considering replacing her
with another
female representative.
This is all over Congresswoman
Cheney telling the truth,
refusing to back down
from her criticisms
of former President Trump
and the lies
he continues to spread
about voter fraud
in the last election.
-All right, first of all, Mitt,
maybe they weren't saying "boo."
Maybe they were saying,
"Who? Who?"
-Who let the dogs out?
Who? Who?
-You guys remember that
golden oldie? Simpler times.
Of course, that would have
never happened to Trump
because he would never
have asked it as a question.
"We all know who let
the dogs out, folks.
Sleepy Joe, and you're
hearing it very strongly.
He fell asleep
with the door open.
All the dogs ran away.
But we're bringing them back,
folks.
We're bringing back our jobs,
and we're bringing back
our dogs,
and, of course, we're
bringing back Dogs with Jobs.
Oh, they had police dogs
and service dogs,
and maybe they did it
for the treats,
or maybe they were
great patriots.
Who knows?
But you're seeing it now
more and more.
Who? Who-who?"
Also, one of the many [bleep]
things about the modern
Republican Party
is that they're making me
defend people like Mitt Romney
and Liz Cheney.
You think I want to side
with Liz Cheney?
For one thing, she's never met
a war she didn't support,
and I'm afraid that
if I'm too nice to her,
her dad will invite me hunting
and shoot me in the face.
But this isn't about Liz Cheney
or Mitt Romney.
You don't have to agree
with them on anything else.
It's about why
she's being punish.
She's being punished
simply for living in reality.
That's it.
And now House GOP Leader
Kevin McCarthy,
who also made the same sad
pilgrimage to Mar-a-Lago
as Ted Cruz
is signaling that he's
finally ready to push her out
in favor of someone who will
back Trump's big election lie.
-I have heard from members
concerned about her ability
to carry out the job
as conference chair,
to carry out the message.
-Media obtained this audio, this
hot-mic audio of McCarthy today
before an interview on Fox
this morning.
Listen to it.
-I think she's got
real problems.
I've had it with --
I've had it with her.
It's -- You know,
I've lost confidence.
Well, someone just has to bring
a motion,
but I assume that will
probably take place.
-I'm surprised he got caught
on a hot mic
because I just assumed
Fox News was the hot mic.
That's where you go to say
all the dumb [bleep]
you can't say anywhere else.
You can go on Fox
and claim Biden
is going to outlaw hamburgers,
and the anchors
will take you seriously.
But if you say the same thing
on the sidewalk in Times Square,
people would look away
or pretend not to speak English.
I've pulled that move
walking to work many times.
"Excuse me,
will you sign my petition
to stop the President
from banning our hamburgers
and putting microchips
in our DNA?"
Scusi, non parlo inglese.
Mi chiamo Gabagool.
This Republican Party
doesn't seem to stand...
[ Laughter ]
This Republican Party
doesn't seem to stand for
anything other than
seeking power
and doing anything possible
to attain it,
including dismantling democracy.
They're so fully committed
to Trump's big election lie
that they're now punishing a
long-time hard-core conservative
just for living in reality.
I'm running out of words to
describe how insane this is,
so I'll just have to start
making up new ones, like...
-Jack-a-loons.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wear a mask.
Get vaccinated. We love you.